donc nos chroniqueurs nous d'ici à
rooney le nouveau khalife des comics on
regarde un extrait de son spectacle pour
je paye ses propos enfin pas que je suis
antisémite
j'ai maintenant mais non j'ai pas aimé
non mais tu veux pas
ils sont 1,8 milliard j'ai pas assez
d'amour pour un luminaire de personnes
j'ai déjà je les connais pas tout en
plus je veux pas et met en lumière des
personnes tu peux aimer les indiens
kayapo dans la zone i t il soit ils sont
22 la semaine prochaine ils sont quinze
mandats un pote musulmans j'ai dit
pourquoi les femmes elles portent le
voile ds pour cacher leurs cheveux pour
passer du réseau vient donc toi la
formation ce que tu regardes une femme
c'est les cheveux le mend migratoires à
manille moi c'est des monnaies par les
monnaies
voilà pas le voile à la chaussette de
[ __ ] d'abord connue dans des petites
salles
et puis le succès mu maintenant c'est
edouard 7 et il a pignon sur rue et il a
pris la prix de l'essence 1 et eric et
13h vous êtes très attentif au stand up
en général mais est ce que vous pensez
de celui très attentifs et est un peu
épuisés par moments c'était complet mais
un point et pas un stage de vide moi
j'ai trouvé deux trois choses singulier
briand est facile je trouve que
justement qui met à la monte beaucoup de
ses confrères de stand-up
parce que finalement les sujets qu'ils
traitent ces des sujets que je traite un
peu tout le monde sait le conflit sera
aux palestiniens la religion et ses
dérives un peu de roman polanski par là
ça fait jamais de mal un peu plus le
communautarisme et souhaité que
simplement il y en a beaucoup qui se
sert des sujets je trouve que lui
laissèrent et c'est ça qui est différent
et brion parce qu'il ya au delà du texte
si un rythme
il ya un flou il ya une espièglerie ça
vous faire plaisir c'est vrai que vous
adorez c'est que moi ça m'a fait penser
à ce qu'on veut faire vincent delerm sur
scène c'est que ça vous touche au caire
en 10 ans avançant de lancer cette
capacité mesures seront effectuées à
mais n'est pas parce que mais parce que
vu que j'ai un problème d'insomnie je
passe du dollar
mais pourquoi je dis ça pourquoi vie ça
c'est parce que vous n'avez ou alors je
veux bien évidemment puisque vous avez
vous avez des idées préconçues il
voulait pas en bouger n'est pas les voir
sur scène et sur scène entre les
chansons je préfère marcher moi il fait
ça nous avait tort parce que parfois on
peut dormir en bonne compagnie en une
dans un théâtre et il a une manière de
justement de savoir poser les silences
où il faut et c'est le cas de lui et je
dis enfin facile parce que lorsqu'on a
un tel talent lorsqu'on a un tel style
ya tendance parfois à la blague de trop
et on se dit non pourquoi
une énième blague sur marine le pen
pourquoi une énième blague sur robert
ménard qui donc ne sert à rien puisque
on les a déjà entendus
est-ce que ça doit être genre pas il
faut être être contre eux oh si on l'est
on le sera et je trouve que c'est
dommage qu'un tel talent on ne soient
pas dépouillés de ses scories là vous
nous donnerez la note tout à l'heure pas
maintenant maintenant c'est à la fin du
tour de table c'est moi qui me goure
depuis le début le début de l'émission
en fait yann alors je là je suis pas
allé le voir mais tant qu'à crever
génique ce que c'est que j'avais vu
quand je faisais pas on n'est pas couché
bahanack à l'époque nous gagner déjà à
l'époque il me faisait pas rire du tout
mais mais mais c'est pas de sa faute
c'est simplement que jeune vraiment à
part franck dubosc quelqu'un de très
drôle sur scène qui fait de l'humour
donc je sais qu'il est là pour 1h43
qu'il est payé pour ça qu'il a peaufiné
ses blagues depuis 18 mois avec une
équipe
rien que ça déjà c'est comme utile une
fille qui me dit un terreau à me faire
jouir
il ya un an chez un blocage non mais je
veux dire
non mais c'est il ya une obligation
quasiment sociologique d'avoir à rire
qui déjà provoque chez moi une sorte de
retrait même pas de blocage de retrait
en plus j'avais trouvé gestion qui
tristement les mêmes reproches mais
c'était un ancien spectacle que toujours
par souci de se garder une ceinture de
sécurité
il ya toujours la démagogie ambiante qui
fait qu on tapera sur des figures
maintenant ceux qui ont tellement
d'hématomes qu'on peut même plus les
voir et donc voilà j'avais trouvé ça
scolaire à l'époque
donc vous n'avez en retard à l'école
m'enchante pas plus que ça d'accord
d'accord est une bonne conclusion va
prendre l'avis de catherine moi je dis
juste que ce que j'aime chez haroun
c'est que justement sur l'islam le
communautarisme qui est vraiment qu'elle
était bien bien abordé par ses confrères
il a une manière de faire un pas de côté
double x et bien après là où ça marche
moins bien c'est quand ils essaient de
faire des phrases très très longue et
l'humour ce deal eu un peu il est bon
dans la punchline
il ya aidés qu'ils essaient de
développer j'ai l'impression que il se
perd un peu dans les trucs mais le
public suit un fou reconnaît public est
au rendez vous et le public trouve ça
drôle catherine moi j'ai vu ce spectacle
j'ai retrouvé mort dans sa chambre
c'est pour moi c'est sa force est un peu
long ce qui me fascine et moi au
contraire c'est les comparer d'économie
de mots avec constance debré mais c'est
l'économie de gestes tout est dans le
verbe la pulsion du verbe le silence
alors on aime ou on n'aime pas les
mourres apprécier encore il se déplace
un petit peu plus que par l'arjel et
j'allais venir et pour moi c'est la
force du spectacle et puis patatras il
va dans des facilités que tu as cité
dont j'y reviendrai pas m'aider sans
doute une mauvaise conscience de dire
merde je bouge pas depuis deux heures
s'il est vraiment et mobiles avec une
table à côté il faut que je voulais un
peu pour joindre un petit peu aux
spectateurs c'est une erreur hélas mal
je m'adresse aux producteurs parce
qu'elle peut lutter ils font pas leur
job dans ces cas là parce que qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un producteur pour un
artiste c'est son premier spectateur
après son miroir et sa femme et c'est à
lui de dire tu coupes ton spectacle
il est un petit peu trop long ça déborde
et on était on l'a vu avec quand c'est
trop long
on vous dit souvent c'est trop rapide
paraît qu'ils sont donc ces tags rendre
service à un artiste lui dire fais plus
court créé la demande alors une suite
logique aux oreilles ces gesticulations
à la fin n'apporte pas grand chose on
tombe dans la facilité
il ya quinze minutes en trop donc bon
spectacle un petit peu sabordé par ses
erreurs de jeunesse où tu sais pas quoi
de mauvaises productions on va dire nous
donnerait la note tout à l'heure mais
moi j'observe qu'au théâtre il ya
souvent 15 minutes de trop et a souvent
mauvais producteurs au théâtre il faut
le dire en face dure 15 minutes
rapidement c'est bien les crises en peut
pas lui enlever
moi j'ai paris une seule fois alors que
je suis plutôt rieuse ouais non mais
c'est alors là c'est bien une seule fois
mais vraiment pas tes du fabec oui alors
c'est parce que sinon on va vers le oui
mais c'était pas ce soir là non vraiment
j'ai trouvé ces boucles trop entendu moi
je fais une overdose en plus de
l'exercice stand-up je peux plus faire
que vraiment j'arrive vraiment à satiété
quand je vois qu'il ya d'autres artistes
par exemple pour n'en nommer qu'un qui
est monsieur fresque en train de
réinventer le seul en scène
voilà il se passe quelque chose ça j'ai
vu huit cent mille fois par contre c'est
vrai que c'est très bien écrit que son
voile assez geste us sont un petit peu
si on aime parure c'est un spectacle que
vous recommandez vous voilà tout sourire
dans les mois je suis pas je suis quand
même un bon baromètre que moi je suis
très client justement gras n'est pas
forcément signe d'un bon spectacle
c'est que vraiment c'est ce qu'il
propres et qu'elle nous présente il le
fait bien mais sait on a tellement déjà
entendu le pont pour cette façon plus
fine c'est ce qu'ont révélé ça vaut être
fin ma foi voilà c'est même la finesse
j'ai entendu plus faim voilà donc je
suis vraiment navré parce que par contre
je suis vraiment je suis toujours très
admirative du culot qu'il faut pour
monter sur scène je sais que c'est très
dur qu'il a il vient de loin il s'est
battu pour être là où il est aujourd'hui
donc ça me gêne un peu et là pour le
coup je peux pas mentir j'ai vraiment
pas aimé donc j'ai mis aussi une petite
note qu'on va découvrir maintenant
maintenant c'est l'heure de nantes j'ai
mis un petit 5 ha oui ces peuples
sémites 5,8 4e 7 pts 7
non j'avais j'ai noté j'ai mis 5 vous à
l'époque d'après vos souvenirs
oui
si ç'avait été en temps réel j'aurais
mis trois ans à 6 ans et demi j'ai mis
un petit chez pc oui ça va je pense avec
la moyenne à peu près dans quelques mois
je représente le peuple je suis dit
voilà je suis dans le calcul mental
alors je cours aussi bien avec ma propre
poche qui était un peu normal 6,3 c'est
à dire payer
je pense que c'est la trêve ils pillent
et rêver on entend plus alors c'est un
peu sévère
un petit